Bienvenido de nuevo a Entendiendo la información y la computación cuántica. Mi nombre es John Wattress y soy el director técnico de educación en IBM
Quantum. Esta es la lección 16 y última de la serie, y el tema es la computación cuántica tolerante a fallos.
A lo largo de las tres lecciones anteriores, hemos visto varios ejemplos de códigos de corrección de errores cuánticos que pueden detectar y permitirnos
corregir errores cuánticos siempre que no ocurran demasiados. Sin embargo, si queremos usar la corrección de errores para la computación cuántica, todavía hay muchos
problemas que enfrentar, incluyendo la realidad de que nuestros quantum gates, mediciones y preparaciones de estado
probablemente sean imperfectos. Así que, por ejemplo, si vamos a realizar corrección de errores en uno
o más qubits que han sido codificados usando un código de corrección de errores cuánticos, tendremos que hacerlo con gates y mediciones que a su vez
tienen posibilidad de no funcionar correctamente. Y eso significa no solo fallar en detectar o corregir errores, sino posiblemente
introducir nuevos errores. Además, también necesitamos realizar los cálculos que nos interesan, de nuevo con gates que no son
perfectos. Y desde luego no podemos arriesgarnos a decodificar información cuántica para realizar los cálculos y luego
volver a codificarla al terminar, porque podrían ocurrir errores cuando no está presente la protección de un código de corrección de errores cuánticos.
Eso significa que tenemos que encontrar la manera de aplicar quantum gates directamente sobre qubits lógicos que nunca queden sin la
protección de un código de corrección de errores cuánticos. Esto es una tarea difícil, pero se sabe que siempre que el nivel de ruido
caiga por debajo de cierto valor umbral, es de hecho posible realizar computaciones cuánticas arbitrariamente grandes de forma confiable usando hardware ruidoso, al menos
en teoría. Y discutiremos este hecho de importancia crítica más adelante en la lección. Aquí hay un breve resumen de la
lección. Comenzaremos con un modelo básico para la computación cuántica tolerante a fallos, incluyendo una breve discusión
de modelos de ruido junto con una metodología general para implementar un quantum circuit de forma tolerante a
fallos. Luego pasaremos al problema de la propagación de errores en quantum circuits tolerantes a fallos y cómo
controlarla. En particular, hablaré sobre implementaciones de gates transversales, que ofrecen una forma muy sencilla de controlar la propagación de errores.
Aunque hay una limitación fundamental que nos impide usar este método
de forma exclusiva. También hablaré sobre una metodología diferente que involucra los llamados estados mágicos, que ofrece un camino distinto para controlar los errores de propagación
en quantum circuits tolerantes a fallos. Aunque no es el único método conocido, y por último, la lección
concluye con una discusión bastante general del teorema umbral, al que aludí hace un momento.
Este teorema establece que quantum circuits arbitrariamente grandes pueden implementarse de forma confiable siempre que la tasa de error de todos los componentes
involucrados caiga por debajo de cierto valor umbral finito. En general, este valor umbral
depende del código de corrección de errores que usemos, así como de las elecciones específicas que hagamos para las implementaciones tolerantes a fallos de
quantum gates y mediciones, pero no del tamaño del circuit que se implementa. Y esto nos da una buena razón para creer que las computaciones cuánticas a gran escala
algún día serán una realidad. Comenzaremos discutiendo un modelo básico para la computación cuántica tolerante a fallos
que está basado, de forma natural, en quantum circuits y códigos de corrección de errores cuánticos. Para esta discusión,
imaginemos que tenemos un quantum circuit que queremos implementar, como el que se muestra aquí. Este resulta ser
un circuit de teletransportación que incluye la preparación del EBIT. Pero los detalles no importan realmente para esta discusión. Y podrías imaginar que
este es cualquier otro quantum circuit, posiblemente uno mucho más grande que incluya preparaciones de estado, operaciones unitarias
y mediciones. Este circuit, por supuesto, representa un ideal, y una
implementación real del mismo no será perfecta. La pregunta natural que hay que hacerse es: ¿qué podría salir
mal? Bueno, hay bastantes cosas que podrían salir mal. Por ejemplo, las inicializaciones de estado generalmente no serán
perfectas. Por supuesto, los gates unitarios no serán perfectos, y tampoco lo serán las
mediciones. Además, los propios qubits serán susceptibles al ruido, incluyendo la decoherencia, en cada momento
del cómputo, incluso cuando no les está pasando nada y simplemente están almacenando información cuántica. En otras palabras, prácticamente
todo podría salir mal. Hay una excepción, aunque, o al menos esa es la suposición típica, y
es que cualquier cómputo clásico involucrado probablemente no será defectuoso, porque a todos los efectos
los cómputos clásicos son básicamente perfectos. Así que, por ejemplo, si ejecutamos un algoritmo de emparejamiento clásico para
calcular correcciones para errores del surface code, realmente no necesitamos preocuparnos de que ese cómputo clásico pueda ser defectuoso. Pero cualquier cosa que directamente
involucre información cuántica podría serlo. Por supuesto, necesitamos un modelo preciso con el que podamos asociar
probabilidades para que distintas cosas salgan mal. Y si quisiéramos, podríamos elaborar un modelo tan complicado como quisiéramos para reflejar lo que
realmente ocurre en la realidad. Sin embargo, si el modelo es demasiado complicado, podría resultar difícil o imposible de manejar o de extraer
conclusiones interesantes. Un ejemplo muy sencillo de modelo de ruido que la gente considera frecuentemente
es el modelo de ruido estocástico independiente, donde los errores o fallos que afectan distintos componentes en distintos
momentos, o en otras palabras, distintas ubicaciones en el circuit, son independientes.
Por ejemplo, podríamos decir que cada gate falla con cierta probabilidad, que los bit flips y phase flips ocurren en qubits almacenados con una
probabilidad diferente por unidad de tiempo, y así sucesivamente. Pero la suposición es que no hay correlación entre los distintos
errores. Ahora bien, podrías objetar a ese modelo porque probablemente habrá algunas correlaciones entre
los errores. Por ejemplo, probablemente haya una pequeña posibilidad de un error catastrófico que elimine todos los qubits de una vez.
O quizás con mayor probabilidad, podría haber errores localizados que, sin embargo, afecten a múltiples componentes.
Y nadie afirma lo contrario. Sin embargo, este modelo sí representa una línea base sencilla que en
esencia representa la idea de que la naturaleza es impredecible, pero no es maliciosa y no intenta arruinar intencionalmente
las computaciones cuánticas. Hay otros modelos de ruido más realistas que se consideran frecuentemente. Y sea cual sea el
modelo que elijamos, si resulta que nuestro modelo nos lleva por el camino equivocado y aprendemos algo nuevo sobre los errores en
el sistema con el que trabajamos, podemos formular y considerar de forma natural distintos modelos de error. A continuación, vamos a echar
un vistazo a una estrategia básica para implementar quantum circuits de forma tolerante a fallos. Así que consideremos un
quantum circuit lógico dado, es decir, un quantum circuit ideal que nos interesa ejecutar. Por ejemplo, podríamos considerar el mismo circuit que
antes, que ahora está un poco más extendido porque vamos a necesitar un poco más de espacio para la implementación tolerante a fallos del mismo. En primer lugar,
las preparaciones de estado, los gates unitarios y las mediciones no se realizarán directamente como gates individuales o como
mediciones o preparaciones de estado de un solo qubit, sino que se realizarán mediante los llamados gadgets, que
cada uno podría involucrar múltiples qubits y múltiples operaciones. Aquí en este diagrama,
lo ilustré dibujando cajas moradas alrededor de estas cosas. Y puedes pensar en estas cajas moradas como pequeños circuits u operaciones que están
simplemente etiquetadas por el estado de preparación o gate que pretendemos implementar. En segundo lugar, necesitamos proteger
los qubits usando un código de corrección de errores. Así que no serán los qubits lógicos en sí los que conecten estos diferentes gadgets, sino que los gadgets actúan sobre
los qubits físicos que codifican estos qubits lógicos. Y vale la pena destacar aquí que los qubits lógicos que nos importan
nunca están expuestos, lo que significa que estos qubits lógicos pasarán toda su vida siendo protegidos por cualquier
código de corrección de errores cuánticos que estemos usando. Y finalmente, realizamos corrección de errores en nuestros qubits codificados
repetidamente a lo largo de la computación, básicamente cada vez que tengamos la oportunidad. Y es de vital importancia que lo hagamos.
De forma intuitiva, a medida que ocurren errores, la aleatoriedad o incertidumbre comienza a acumularse en el estado de nuestros
qubits y necesitamos trabajar constantemente para eliminar esta aleatoriedad o entropía. Y esto sucede a través de la corrección de errores.
Así que puedes pensar en estos pasos de corrección de errores como pequeños refrigeradores lógicos o bombas de calor que
permiten que los qubits lógicos se mantengan fríos para que la computación pueda funcionar correctamente.
Una vez que se han tomado todas estas decisiones, es decir, la selección de todos los gadgets así como el código y asumiendo un modelo de ruido particular, hay una
pregunta fundamental que podemos hacernos, y es: ¿esto realmente está ayudando? ¿Estamos mejorando las cosas o
las estamos empeorando? Si hay demasiado ruido, podríamos estar empeorando las cosas perfectamente,
igual que el código Shore de 9Q empeora las cosas si la probabilidad de error es demasiado alta.
Pero si el ruido está por debajo de cierto umbral, entonces todo este trabajo adicional nos llevará a algún lugar. Y como veremos hacia el final de la lección,
se abren caminos para reducir aún más el error. En esta parte de la lección, hablaremos sobre la propagación de errores en los
circuits cuánticos tolerantes a fallos con la estructura básica que acabo de describir. Resulta ser una
preocupación principal porque si no logramos controlar la propagación de errores, los errores rápidamente abrumarán nuestros esfuerzos de
corrección de errores. Pero si somos capaces de controlar la propagación de errores, entonces nuestro código tendrá muchas más posibilidades
de mantenerse al día para que los errores puedan corregirse a una tasa lo suficientemente alta como para permitir que nuestras computaciones
funcionen. El punto de partida de esta discusión es la comprensión de que los gates de dos qubits o de múltiples qubits más
en general pueden propagar errores incluso cuando funcionan correctamente.
Por ejemplo, considera un gate C-not. Y supón que ocurre un error X en el qubit de control justo antes de que el gate C-not
sea ejecutado. Bueno, un error X funciona igual que un gate X. Y encontramos que
el circuit de la izquierda es equivalente al de la derecha, donde los errores X ocurren en ambos qubits después del C-not.
Esto es una propagación de errores porque la desafortunada ubicación del error X en la izquierda efectivamente lo convierte
en dos errores X en la derecha. Y nunca vamos a poder evitar esto. Siempre que usemos gates C-not, siempre habrá
una posibilidad de que ocurra un error X en el qubit de control justo antes, que luego se propaga a dos errores X
después. Pero como veremos, siempre que tomemos medidas para limitar el daño que esto causa, estaremos bien. Y por cierto,
el mismo fenómeno ocurre cuando tenemos un error Z en el qubit objetivo justo antes de un C-not. Y discutimos esto
antes y puedes verificar estas igualdades simplemente realizando las multiplicaciones o puedes verificarlas usando
Qiskit. La conclusión es que en ambos casos esto causará errores correlacionados en múltiples qubits. Y por supuesto,
no debemos olvidar que los propios gates C-not también podrían ser defectuosos, lo que también puede causar errores correlacionados.
Sumándose a nuestra preocupación, los gates de dos qubits subsiguientes podrían propagar estos errores aún más.
Por ejemplo, si tenemos tres gates C-not como este, igual que encontramos cuando medimos generadores de estabilizadores X, por ejemplo, entonces un solo error puede
propagarse rápidamente a múltiples qubits. Y si esto ocurre dentro de un solo bloque de código, por ejemplo, es decir, un conjunto de
qubits que juntos codifican un qubit lógico, cualquier código de corrección de errores que hayamos elegido no va a tener
ninguna posibilidad porque los códigos están diseñados para corregir errores de bajo peso, no errores de alto peso como este.
Y por eso esto es algo que tenemos que tener en mente en primer plano, de hecho, mientras pensamos en los gadgets y en los
pasos de corrección de errores en los circuits cuánticos tolerantes a fallos. La manera más simple conocida para mitigar la propagación de errores en los
circuits cuánticos tolerantes a fallos es implementar los gates de forma transversal, y explicaré qué significa eso
en un momento. Así que mantengamos la figura de nuestra implementación del circuit tolerante a fallos en pantalla solo como ayuda visual.
La idea aquí es que para algunos códigos de corrección de errores cuánticos, ciertos gates pueden implementarse de forma transversal, lo que
significa implementarlos usando gadgets que son productos tensoriales de operaciones donde cada operación actúa únicamente sobre un
único qubit dentro de cada bloque de código. Esto es más fácil de explicar con algunos ejemplos. El primero y
probablemente el más simple es la implementación transversal de gates de Pauli.
La idea es que queremos construir gadgets para cada uno de los gates en nuestro circuit. Y en todos los casos, esos gadgets
operan sobre bloques de código tal como vemos para los gates X y Z al final de nuestro circuit de teletransportación. Por supuesto,
no podemos decodificar, aplicar un gate de Pauli y luego recodificar porque eso dejaría un qubit lógico desprotegido y los errores
podrían propagarse dentro del bloque de código como resultado de la recodificación.
Afortunadamente, no necesitamos hacer eso siempre que usemos un código estabilizador, porque todo código estabilizador permite que las
operaciones de Pauli se apliquen directamente a nuestros qubits lógicos. Y de hecho, podemos hacer eso con un producto tensorial de gates de Pauli
sobre los qubits físicos utilizados para la codificación.
Por ejemplo, si consideramos el código de superficie 3x3 que surgió al final de la lección anterior, entonces podemos implementar los gates X y Z en el qubit lógico
codificado por este código combinando mediante producto tensorial los gates X y Z junto con los gates identidad en los patrones que se
sugieren aquí. Esta es una implementación transversal de estos gates porque cada una de estas operaciones de gate individuales
actúa únicamente sobre un único qubit dentro de cada bloque de código.
Aquí solo estamos usando gates de un solo qubit, así que es algo trivial en cierto modo, pero en cualquier caso, gadgets como este no harán que los errores se
propaguen. Ahora bien, cualquiera de los gates individuales en un gadget como este podría fallar, y eso introducirá
errores, pero siempre realizaremos la corrección de errores inmediatamente después de cada gadget. Y siempre que la tasa de error sea
suficientemente baja, el código de corrección de errores corregirá esos errores.
Y como dije, esto siempre es posible para los gates de Pauli en todo código estabilizador.
Aunque sí hay que identificar el patrón correcto de gates de Pauli en los gadgets para implementar correctamente cualquier operación de Pauli lógica que vayas
Por ejemplo, uno que sí involucra dos gates cúbicas. Esta vez podemos considerar implementaciones transversales
de gates C not. En particular, para todo código CSS, siempre podemos implementar un gate C not
entre dos qubits lógicos simplemente ejecutando gates C not en los pares correspondientes de qubits físicos
y esto cumple la condición de ser transversal porque cada uno de estos gates C not individuales actúa solo
en una única posición de qubit dentro de cada bloque de código. Por ejemplo, el primer gate C not actúa solo en el qubit superior
dentro de cada bloque de código, el segundo gate C not actúa solo en el segundo qubit desde arriba, y así
sucesivamente. En este caso podría haber propagación de errores porque los gates C not propagan errores y no hay
manera de evitarlo. Pero lo clave es que la propagación de errores nunca ocurre dentro de un único bloque de código. Por ejemplo,
un error X podría ocurrir en el qubit superior del bloque de código superior justo antes de que se ejecute el gadget, y el primer C not
dentro del gadget propagará ese error al qubit superior del bloque inferior. Pero los dos errores resultantes están
ahora en bloques de código separados. Entonces los pasos de corrección de errores que ocurren después del gadget podrán corregir esos errores individualmente, porque esos
errores solo afectan a un único qubit dentro de cada bloque de código.
En cambio, si la propagación de errores ocurriera dentro del mismo bloque de código, podríamos tener un problema porque la
propagación de errores estaría convirtiendo un error de bajo peso en uno de mayor peso que nuestro código podría no ser capaz de manejar.
Esta implementación no funciona para códigos no CSS, pero siempre que usemos un código CSS, siempre podemos implementar C not
gates de forma transversal de esta manera. Y como un ejemplo más, todo
gate de Clifford puede implementarse transversalmente para el código de Steane. Y de hecho para cualquier código de color, que es una de las cosas realmente buenas de los códigos de
color; en particular, un gate Hadamard sobre un qubit lógico puede implementarse ejecutando gates Hadamard individualmente en
cada uno de los qubits físicos, y un gate S lógico puede implementarse no con un gate S en cada qubit, sino con un
gate S dagger en cada qubit físico. Así que la conclusión es que las implementaciones de gates transversales son inherentemente
tolerantes a fallos porque nunca propagan errores dentro de un único bloque de código, lo que le da a la corrección de errores una oportunidad real de corregir
cualquier error introducido o propagado por los gates usados en estos gadgets. Eso es genial y es una
forma muy sencilla de construir gadgets tolerantes a fallos, y hay distintos códigos que permiten implementaciones transversales de distintos gates, como
los gates T; pero lamentablemente es imposible para cualquier código no trivial implementar un
conjunto universal de gates de forma transversal, lo cual es un hecho conocido como el teorema de Eastin-Knill. En términos más técnicos, lo que
dice es que, siempre que nuestro código tenga distancia al menos dos, el conjunto de gates que pueden implementarse transversalmente generará necesariamente un
conjunto discreto de operaciones salvo una fase global, y por lo tanto ese conjunto no es universal porque los conjuntos de gates universales
generan necesariamente infinitas operaciones. No voy a explicar la demostración de este teorema, que utiliza algunos
hechos básicos sobre grupos y álgebras de Lie, que no son prerequisitos para esta serie. Pero la idea básica es
que las familias infinitas de operaciones transversales no pueden mantenernos dentro del espacio de código porque las mínimas
diferencias en operaciones transversales se aproximan bien mediante operaciones de bajo peso de Pauli, que el código detecta como
errores. Así que nos alegra mucho poder implementar gates de forma transversal. Pero para cualquier código que elijamos, sabemos que
siempre habrá algunos gates que no podemos implementar así. Por eso necesitamos buscar gadgets alternativos. Por el
teorema de Eastin-Knill, sabemos que no es posible implementar un conjunto universal de gates cuánticos transversalmente, ni siquiera
para un código de corrección de errores cuántico de distancia 2. Así que necesitamos encontrar otras formas de implementar gates de manera tolerante
a fallos, al menos para algunos gates. Una forma bien conocida de hacerlo es mediante el uso de los llamados estados
mágicos. Para los fines de esta discusión, recordemos los gates S y T, que son
gates de un solo qubit definidos como se muestra aquí en pantalla. Observemos también que, primero, S es una operación de Clifford,
lo cual se desprende de nuestra definición de operaciones de Clifford. Pero también puedes verificar que conjugar una matriz de Pauli por S siempre nos da más o menos otra
matriz de Pauli. Y segundo, T no es una operación de Clifford. De hecho, si combinamos T con Hadamard y C not, ambos
operaciones de Clifford, obtenemos un conjunto universal de gates cuánticos. Así que no podemos implementar un gate T
usando solo operaciones de Clifford y mediciones en la base estándar. Pero sí podemos implementar un gate T usando
operaciones de Clifford y mediciones en la base estándar si además tenemos una copia del estado que se muestra aquí en
pantalla, que es el gate T aplicado a un estado más.
Este estado se llama estado mágico, aunque no es el único en ese sentido.
El término estado mágico también se usa para referirse a distintos estados que juegan un papel similar a este en variaciones de todo este
esquema. Por ejemplo, este circuit que se muestra aquí hace el trabajo. Y no es demasiado difícil comprobarlo.
Aquí está el estado inicial con el sistema superior a la derecha. Si aplicamos el gate C not y simplificamos, obtenemos el
estado que se muestra aquí.
Entonces, si medimos el qubit inferior y obtenemos un cero, lo cual ocurre con probabilidad 1/2, no ejecutamos el
gate S y la salida es T aplicado a s.
Y si medimos uno, lo que también ocurre con probabilidad 1/2, por supuesto, sí aplicamos el gate S y el resultado neto es
que la salida es de nuevo T aplicado a s. Por cierto, esta no es la única forma de hacerlo. Hay otros circuits similares
que logran la misma tarea, pero esta es una de ellas.
Este es un ejemplo algo simplificado de algo conocido como teletransportación cuántica de gates, a lo que aludí en la lección 4, donde la teletransportación se usa
no para enviar qubits, sino para aplicar gates. La conexión con la teletransportación puede no ser del todo clara aquí porque, como
dije, esta es una versión simplificada, con la que podemos salir adelante porque T es diagonal. Pero si te interesa
aprender más, las palabras clave son teletransportación cuántica de gates.
Y también podríamos hacer algo similar para implementar un gate S, donde en este caso los únicos gates que necesitamos son un gate C not y un gate Z junto con la medición,
lo cual es útil si no tenemos una implementación transversal de un gate S. Eso es interesante, pero no
queda del todo claro que esto ayude en realidad. En el caso de la implementación del gate T, por ejemplo, estamos
logrando aplicar un gate T a un estado de entrada. Pero para eso, parece que estamos aplicando un gate T a un estado más para obtener un
estado mágico. Y la situación es similar para la implementación del gate S. El punto es que no
necesariamente tenemos que crear primero un estado más y luego aplicar un gate T para obtener un estado mágico. Hay otras formas posibles de obtener ese estado. Y en
particular, podemos hacerlo sin tener que preocuparnos por propagar errores en el cómputo en que estemos trabajando, porque los estados mágicos pueden crearse
por separado. Esto permite una implementación tolerante a fallos de una compuerta T, como describiré brevemente a continuación.
Primero, en realidad no vamos a ejecutar el simple circuit de dos qubits que se muestra aquí, sino que ejecutaremos este circuit usando
qubits codificados en cualquier código corrector de errores que estemos usando para nuestra implementación tolerante a fallos. Lo que significa que las
compuertas unitarias y las mediciones se realizan mediante gadgets tolerantes a fallos. Y eso significa que también necesitamos que nuestros
estados mágicos estén codificados también. Así que todo será tolerante a fallos siempre que podamos conseguir
estados mágicos codificados. Aquí estamos asumiendo, por cierto, que ya tenemos un gadget tolerante a fallos para una compuerta S. Si
estuviéramos usando el código de Steane, por ejemplo, podríamos simplemente implementar la compuerta S de forma transversal. Y para los códigos en los que eso no funciona, una opción es
usar todo este esquema para implementar una compuerta S de forma tolerante a fallos y luego usar esa implementación aquí.
Aunque esa no es la única opción. Pero de todas formas, volviendo a la implementación, la pregunta importante que queda es cómo conseguimos
un estado mágico codificado dado que aún no tenemos una implementación tolerante a fallos de una compuerta T para facilitar eso.
Y la idea clave es que podemos usar un proceso probabilístico para crear estados mágicos codificados. Y si no
resulta funcionar, no hay problema. Podemos simplemente descartar los intentos fallidos y volver a intentarlo.
Y eso no perturba la computación que realmente estamos intentando realizar, porque la creación de estados mágicos se hace
por separado. Una forma típica de hacer esto es mediante un proceso conocido como destilación de estados mágicos. Y funciona así:
Tenemos un cierto circuit conocido como destilador. Introducimos en este destilador una colección de estados mágicos ruidosos
y luego medimos todos los outputs menos uno. Y si condicionamos a que todos los resultados de la medición sean cero,
lo que ocurre es que lo que sale es un estado mágico con menos ruido, que puede ser uno de los qubits introducidos en
otro destilador. Y el proceso continúa hasta que o bien fallamos porque uno de los resultados de la medición es distinto de cero y lo intentamos de nuevo, o tenemos un estado mágico
de suficientemente alta calidad como para usarlo de forma segura e implementar una compuerta T en la computación que nos importa.
Hay diferentes formas conocidas de construir un destilador así, pero todas funcionan básicamente de la misma manera, que es que son decodificadores para códigos estabilizadores,
es decir, que son inversas de circuits de codificación, lo cual es conveniente porque significa que el destilador puede ser una operación
de Clifford. Y finalmente, este proceso de destilación es en realidad algo que ocurre a nivel del qubit lógico. Así que en realidad,
todo se hace usando gadgets para el destilador y las mediciones. Este proceso sí tiene que
comenzar en algún punto. Pero siempre que la tasa de ruido no sea demasiado alta, es posible crear estados mágicos ruidosos pero suficientemente buenos
para iniciarlo. Por ejemplo, aplicando una compuerta T ruidosa real a un qubit en un estado más y luego
codificando ese qubit. Eso fue una descripción de muy alto nivel, pero espero haberte dado una idea general de cómo funciona esto.
Es bastante más complicado que implementar compuertas de forma transversal, pero aun así, ofrece una manera de implementar un conjunto universal de
compuertas cuánticas de forma tolerante a fallos, mientras que las implementaciones transversales de compuertas por sí solas no pueden hacer eso. A veces se afirma
que la sobrecarga de usar estados mágicos para implementar compuertas de forma tolerante a fallos siguiendo estas líneas sería muy alta,
donde la gran mayoría del trabajo se dedica a destilar estados mágicos y ejecutar la computación real es más bien algo
secundario. Pero en realidad eso no está tan claro, y ha habido análisis detallados que revelan que este método
podría ser, de hecho, práctico. Hay varios otros esquemas conocidos para implementar compuertas de forma tolerante a fallos. La deformación de código y el cambio de código son nombres
asociados a algunos de estos esquemas, y se siguen desarrollando y refinando nuevas formas, pero no describiré esos
métodos en esta lección. Hay otro problema importante relacionado con las implementaciones tolerantes a fallos de circuits cuánticos y
tiene que ver con los propios pasos de corrección de errores. Así que esto no es sobre implementar compuertas. Se trata de hacer la
corrección de errores real. El problema es que si pensamos en los circuits simples que
vimos por primera vez en la lección 14 para medir generadores estabilizadores basados en estimación de fase, encontramos que no son
en sí mismos tolerantes a fallos porque podrían potencialmente causar que los errores se propaguen dentro de un único bloque de código.
Esto remite a la idea de que todo lo que involucra información cuántica es susceptible a errores, y eso incluye los circuits que están ellos mismos destinados
a corregir errores. Esto parece bastante problemático, pero de hecho hay múltiples soluciones conocidas a este problema. Mencionaré solo algunas de
ellas, aunque no explicaré ninguna en detalle. Y por cierto, si estás captando la idea de que la computación cuántica tolerante a fallos es
complicada y hay muchos detalles de los que preocuparse, eso es completamente comprensible porque es verdad. Hay muchas piezas en movimiento
aquí, y mi intención con esta lección no es explicar todos los detalles, sino darte solo una introducción básica a cómo funciona todo
esto. Un método para la corrección cuántica de errores tolerante a fallos se conoce como corrección de errores de Shor, llamada así por Peter
Shor, quien propuso este método por primera vez. La idea es realizar cada medición del síndrome usando lo que se llama un estado gato,
que es lo mismo que un estado GHZ cuando tenemos tres qubits, pero puede generalizarse a cualquier número de qubits que coincida con el peso del generador estabilizador
que pretendemos medir. En particular, el circuit mostrado aquí funciona para medir un generador estabilizador. Y puede
demostrarse que este método no causa que los errores se propaguen dentro de un bloque de código.
Requiere crear el propio estado gato. Y para que funcione de forma fiable en presencia de errores y compuertas potencialmente defectuosas, el método en realidad
requiere que ejecutemos circuits como este repetidamente y hagamos inferencias sobre dónde pueden haber ocurrido diferentes errores durante el
proceso. Un método alternativo se conoce como corrección de errores de Steane, propuesto por primera vez por Andrew Steane, y este
método funciona de manera diferente y solo funciona para códigos CSS. En este método, en realidad no realizamos las mediciones del síndrome sobre los estados cuánticos codificados
en el circuit que estamos intentando ejecutar, sino que intencionalmente propagamos los errores a un sistema de espacio de trabajo
y luego medimos ese sistema y detectamos los errores de forma clásica. Esta figura mostrada aquí muestra cómo hacer esto para errores X, en cuyo caso el espacio de trabajo
los qubits se inicializan a una codificación de un estado más. Así que esto es básicamente una
implementación transversal de una compuerta C-NOT que no debería hacer nada porque el objetivo está en un estado más. Pero si hay
errores X en los qubits superiores, se propagarán hacia abajo al sistema inferior y serán detectados. También hay un método similar para detectar errores Z,
que no se muestra aquí. También hay un método relacionado conocido como corrección de errores de Knill, propuesto por primera vez por Manny Knill,
y está basado en la teleportación en lugar de una compuerta C-NOT transversal, lo que le permite funcionar para estabilizadores
arbitrarios y no solo para códigos CSS.
Lo último que discutiré en esta lección es un teorema muy importante conocido como el teorema del umbral. Aquí hay un enunciado algo informal
del teorema. Dice que si tenemos cualquier circuit cuántico con n compuertas, donde n puede ser tan grande como queramos, entonces es
posible implementar ese circuit con alta precisión usando un circuit cuántico ruidoso, siempre que el nivel de ruido
esté por debajo de cierto valor umbral que es independiente de n. Y además, no es demasiado costoso hacerlo, en el
sentido de que el tamaño del circuit ruidoso requerido es del orden de n multiplicado por alguna potencia constante del logaritmo de
n. Para enunciar el teorema de forma más rigurosa habría que ser específico sobre el modelo de ruido, lo cual no haré en esta lección.
Por ejemplo, se puede demostrar para el modelo de ruido estocástico independiente que mencioné antes, donde los errores ocurren
de forma independiente en cada posible ubicación del circuit con una probabilidad estrictamente menor que este valor umbral. Pero también se puede
demostrar para modelos de ruido más generales donde puede haber correlaciones entre los errores. Ahora bien, este es un resultado
teórico y la forma típica en que se demuestra no se traduce necesariamente en algo que haríamos en la práctica, pero sigue siendo un
teorema muy importante en términos prácticos. Y la razón es que básicamente dice que no hay ninguna barrera fundamental para realizar
computaciones cuánticas usando componentes con ruido.
Siempre que la tasa de error de estos componentes esté por debajo de este valor umbral, se pueden usar para construir circuits cuánticos confiables de tamaño
arbitrario. Otra forma de decirlo es que si el teorema no fuera cierto, sería difícil imaginar que la computación cuántica a gran escala
pudiera llegar a ser una realidad. Hay muchos detalles técnicos involucrados en las demostraciones formales de este teorema, que no intentaré
explicar. Pero intentaré explicar la idea básica a alto nivel. Y también intentaré conectar de forma aproximada la idea básica
con lo que podríamos esperar que suceda en la práctica. Así que supongamos que este es nuestro circuit. Es el mismo circuit del que
hemos estado hablando durante toda la lección. Pero de nuevo, podemos imaginar que nuestro circuit es significativamente más grande y más complicado que este. Nos gustaría
implementar este circuit, pero todos nuestros componentes tienen ruido. Y suponiendo que usamos el modelo de ruido estocástico independiente
solo por simplicidad, hay una probabilidad P con la que los errores ocurren de forma independiente en cada posible ubicación.
Si el circuit fuera significativamente más grande que el recíproco de esta probabilidad P, podríamos estar bastante seguros de que una
implementación directa de él no funcionaría correctamente. Así que pasamos por todo el proceso de implementar el circuit
de forma tolerante a fallos, como he explicado hasta este punto en la lección, y nos hacemos la pregunta que planteé antes: ¿estamos mejorando las cosas
o las estamos empeorando? Bueno, si la probabilidad P que representa la probabilidad de error para cada uno de nuestros componentes es demasiado grande, entonces
esto no va a ayudar, igual que el código de 9 qubits de Shor no ayuda si la probabilidad de error está por encima del 3 y 4/4% aproximadamente.
En particular, ahora hemos hecho el circuit más grande. Así que hay muchas más ubicaciones donde los errores podrían ocurrir.
Sin embargo, si P es suficientemente pequeño, esto va a ayudar. Y lo que efectivamente haremos es reducir el error
de probabilidad para el cómputo lógico que estamos realizando. Así que pensemos en esto con
un poco más de detalle. Y para ver las ideas principales en un contexto lo más simple posible, supongamos que usamos el código de Steane de 7 qubits para la corrección de
errores, que permite corregir hasta un error por bloque de código. Entonces para que ocurra un error lógico
en el circuit original, tendremos que tener al menos dos errores en el mismo bloque de código para nuestra implementación
tolerante a fallos.
Teniendo en cuenta que hay muchas formas diferentes de tener dos o más errores en el mismo bloque de código, se puede argumentar que la probabilidad de un error
lógico en cada ubicación del circuit original es como máximo C * P ^ 2, donde C es un número que depende del código y de
los gadgets que usamos. Pero, fundamentalmente, no depende del tamaño del circuit original.
Entonces, si P es menor que el recíproco de C, que es el número que podemos tomar como nuestro valor umbral, esto
se traduce en una reducción del error. Así que nuestro esfuerzo al implementar el circuit de forma tolerante a fallos está dando
sus frutos. Sin embargo, esta nueva tasa de error podría ser aún demasiado alta para que el circuit completo funcione correctamente. Así que necesitamos hacer
más. En la práctica, lo más natural en este punto es elegir un código mejor y mejores gadgets para reducir la tasa de error
hasta un punto en el que la implementación probablemente funcione.
Teóricamente hablando, una forma sencilla de argumentar que esto es posible es concatenar. En otras palabras, pensamos
en la implementación tolerante a fallos del circuit original como un nuevo circuit lógico. Y luego lo implementamos de forma tolerante
a fallos. Y luego hacemos esto una y otra vez tantas veces como sea necesario. Y resulta que esto reduce el error
muy rápidamente. Y así es como el teorema umbral se demuestra normalmente en papel.
Te daré solo una idea muy aproximada de cómo disminuye la tasa de error, omitiendo los muchos detalles técnicos necesarios para
demostrarlo formalmente. Comenzamos con la probabilidad de error P para nuestros componentes originales. Y si implementamos el
circuit de forma tolerante a fallos, el error disminuye por un factor de C * P. Si luego tratamos nuestra implementación tolerante a fallos
como un circuit lógico y lo implementamos de forma tolerante a fallos, obtenemos una disminución similar en la tasa de error. Pero
si pensamos en la tasa de error efectiva para el circuit original, vemos que cae aún más porque ahora
estamos reemplazando la tasa de error P por C * P ^ 2, ya que esa es la tasa de error efectiva después del primer nivel de implementación
tolerante a fallos. Específicamente, después de un poco de álgebra, encontramos que el error cae a CP
al cubo * P. Y si lo hacemos de nuevo, ahora tenemos una tasa de error de CP ^ 7 * P. Y si
continuamos haciendo esto para un total de K niveles, lo que encontramos es que el error se reduce de forma doblemente exponencial en K. Así que
no necesitamos hacer esto muchas veces para que la tasa de error sea extremadamente pequeña.
Mientras tanto, los circuits van creciendo en tamaño, pero el tamaño solo aumenta de forma simplemente exponencial en K porque con cada
nivel de tolerancia a fallos, el tamaño de nuestro circuit crece como máximo por un factor determinado por el tamaño máximo de
nuestros gadgets. Y cuando todo se combina y se elige de forma apropiada el número
de niveles de concatenación, obtenemos el teorema umbral. Pero como ya sugerí, hay muchos detalles necesarios para hacer esto formal. Entonces,
¿cuál es este valor umbral en la realidad? Bueno, depende del código y de los gadgets que
usemos para el código de Steane junto con la destilación de estados mágicos. Es minúsculo y probablemente sea poco probable de alcanzar en
la práctica. Pero usando códigos de superficie y gadgets de última generación, se ha estimado que es alrededor del 1%. Lo cual no está
mal. Y a medida que se descubren nuevos códigos y métodos, podemos esperar razonablemente que aumente, mientras que simultáneamente el
nivel de ruido en los componentes que construimos disminuirá. Alcanzar el punto en el que
las computaciones cuánticas a gran escala puedan implementarse de forma tolerante a fallos no será fácil y no sucederá de la noche a la mañana.
Pero este teorema junto con los avances en códigos cuánticos y en hardware cuántico que hemos presenciado hasta la fecha
nos brinda el optimismo que necesitamos para seguir avanzando hacia este objetivo final de construir una
computadora cuántica tolerante a fallos a gran escala. Y ese es el fin de la lección y el fin de la serie. Yo
sinceramente espero que hayas encontrado valor en la serie y, si es así, considera recomendársela a un colega o amigo.
Además, asegúrate de consultar IBM Quantum Learning para cursos y tutoriales adicionales, y suscríbete al canal de Qiskit
en YouTube si aún no lo has hecho, para que puedas mantenerte al día con nuestros futuros lanzamientos de contenido. Gracias por
ver.